Oklahoma City has no offensive rebounds
they've been the best offensive
rebounding team in the NBA
George off-balance it goes a 3-ball for
Paul George for Adams the offense of the
rebound they got a reload George
fires and hits the three as offense to
operate with that kind of stickiness in
the ball they're not getting it off to
the first available player silky smooth
Paul George back in transition they're
very good at it but they like to play
late into the shot clock they found some
angles and seams in this first half
seven to shoot
George crosses challenges Gobert off the
glass Paul George had to adjust because
of go bears presents pitfall when a
rookie is dominating the way that
Mitchell had during parts of this season
George he's got options with either
driving the score make plays will help
them get in their flow they leave Paul
George free and it jams it from
three-point territory conversation with
the officials about the physicality that
we talked about in the first half Paul
George and Engels on that one than
George's big heart to go third quarter
George the handles a breena's over Exim
bought the rim rebounded by George Pizza
the clock
George fires at the heart he's got it
Paul George beats the buzzer over and
over under Billy Donovan the iterations
have been incredible Russell Westbrook
with Kevin Durant as Paul hits two more
86 78 thunder george o'neal goes down
George
[Applause]